let's do some more examples finding
domains of functions so let's add the
function G of X so this is our function
definition here tells us look if we have
a input X the output G of X is going to
be equal to 1 over the square root of 6
- let me write this a little bit neater
1 over the square root of 6 minus the
absolute value of X so like always pause
this video and see if you can figure out
what what is the domain of this function
based on this function definition what
is the domain of G what is the set of
all inputs for which this function is
defined
alright so to think about all of the
inputs that would allow this function to
be defined it might be easy to think
well when does this function not get
defined well if we're divided by 0 then
we're not going to be defined or if we
have a negative under the radical so if
you think about it if if what we have
under the radical is 0 or negative if
it's 0 or negative it's 0 you can take
the you can take the principal root of 0
it's going to be 0 but then you're going
to divide by 0 and that's going to be
undefined and if what you have under the
radical is negative then the principal
root isn't defined for a negative number
or at least the classic principal root
isn't defined for a negative number so
if 6 minus the absolute value of x is 0
or negative this thing isn't going to be
defined or another way to think about it
is it's going to be defined so g-wiz is
defined is defined if G is defined if 6
minus and maybe I could write if and
only if sometimes people write if and
only if with two F's right there if G is
defined if and only if is kind of a
Matthew way of saying if and only if 6
minus the absolute value of x is greater
than 0 it has to be it has to be
positive if it's zero we're going to
take the square root of zero is zero and
you're going to divide by zero that's
undefined and if it's less than zero
then you're taking your trying
find the principal root of a negative
number that's not defined so let's see
it's G is defined if and only if this is
true and let's see we could add the
absolute value of X to both sides we
could add the absolute value of x to
both sides and then that would give us 6
is greater than the absolute value of X
or that the absolute value of X is less
than 6 or we could say that you know let
me write it that way the absolute value
of x is less than 6 or another way of
saying that is X would have to be less
than 6 and greater than negative 6 or X
is between negative 6 and 6 these two
things these two things are equivalent
if the magnitude of X is less than 6
then X is X is greater than negative 6
and less than positive 6 so if we wanted
to write the domain and kind of fancy
domain set notation we could write the
domain of G is going to be X all the X's
that are a member of real numbers such
that negative 6 is less than X which is
less than 6 and we're done
now let's do another one and this one's
going to get even a little bit a little
bit hairier just for just for kicks all
right so let's say that I have let's say
that I have H of X is equal to and I'm
going to have kind of a composite
definition here so let's say it's X plus
10 over X plus 10 times X minus 9 times
X minus 5 times X minus 5 and it's this
if it H of X is this if X does not equal
5 and it's equal to it's equal to PI if
X is equal if X is equal to 5 so once
again pause this video think about what
is the domain of H or another way to
think about when is H not defined so
let's think about it so what would make
H not defined so if some if X is
anything other than 5
we go to this clause if it's five we go
to this clause so in this clause up here
what would make this thing undefined
well the most obvious thing is if we
divide by zero so what's going to cause
us to divide by zero so if if X is equal
to if let me let me write it here so
we're going to divide by zero divided by
zero that would happen if X is equal to
nine that would happen if X is equal to
negative 10 X is equal to negative 10
now we have to be careful would that
happen if this was the only definition
here it would happen when X is equal to
5 but remember what x equals 5 we don't
look at this part of the compound
definition we look at this part so it's
true that up here you would be dividing
by 0 of X equaling 5 but X equaling 5
you would never even look at it look
there if our input is 5 you use this
part of the definition so you would
divide by 0 maybe I should write it this
way divided by 0 on I guess you could
say the top the top Clause or the top
part of definition part of the
definition if x equals 9 x equals
negative 10 or and that's it because x
equals 5 doesn't apply to this top part
if this clause wasn't here then yes you
would write x equals 5 now we're almost
done but some of you might say wait wait
wait but look can't I simplify this I
have X plus 10 in the numerator X plus
10 in the denominator can I just
simplify this and then that'll disappear
and you could except if you did that you
are now creating a different function
definition because if you just simplify
this in his you just said 1 over X minus
9 a 1 over X minus 9 times X minus 5
this is now a different function that
one actually would be defined at x
equals negative 10 but the one that we
have started with this one is not this
is you're going to end up with 0 over 0
you're to end up with that indeterminate
form so for this function exactly the
way it's written it's not going to be
defined when X is equal to 9 or X is
equal to negative 10 so once again if we
want to fight it in our fancy domain set
notation the domain is going to be X all
the X's that are a member of the reals
that X does not equal 9 and X does not
equal negative 10 any other real number
X it's going to work including 5 if x
equals 5 H of H of 5 is going to be
equal to PI because you default to this
one over here H of 5 you say ok x equals
5 we do that one right over there
now if you gave x equals 9 you're going
to divide by 0 x equals negative 10
you're going to divide by 0 what's going
to work for anything else so that right
over there is the domain